are you tired of your boss
are you tired of going to work and
making money for other people's and who
are those people anyways those people
that make money from your work well
they're capitalists they have capital
and they use your labor to make more
capital so if you're tired of going to
work and making money for other people
then you're probably likely just tired
of capitalism which is ironic because
I'm a capitalist I own a small business
our CEO tires in Compton a few years ago
when I read Van Jones and he wrote let's
make green collar jobs in the hood I
took him really seriously
so I co-founded own and operate a tire
recycling company and I'm really proud
of what we've done so far we've recycled
a hundred million pounds of rubber
that's 21 million gallons of oil
diverted from landfills into new
products we also employ about 15 guys
mostly people of color most of whom are
felons and we pay above the minimum wage
and we are now proud members of the
United States Workers Union
now our CEO is not a cooperative now to
privately held company with community
minded ownership but I would like it to
become one I would like for them to fire
the boss that's me and I'm gonna tell
you why but first let me tell you how we
got started so a lot of people asking us
how did our CEO come to be and I have to
be really honest I leveraged my white
privilege so here's how white privilege
worked for me and our CEO my white
grandmother was born on her family's
plantation in Arkansas in 1918 she
traveled with her white father west
following the oil boom and he held
various Union oil jobs jobs which would
have never been given to my black
great-grandfather had he lived here at
the time
granny became a hairdresser and then
used Oh then got a loan with her husband
to build their home in West Los Angeles
alone which would never have been given
to a black family at the time and after
my grandfather passed away my granny was
able to keep that house because she had
his pension and his health care from a
state job which he held which again
would have never been given to a black
man before the anti-discrimination act
of the 1960s so you fast forward 30
years and I graduate and I want to start
my own business with a pile of debt and
a credit card and no experience in the
tire industry but I had what most people
didn't have I had a clean safe free play
flip I'm going to do with my grandmother
and I was able to rent our first
warehouse buy our first truck pay our
first employees because I didn't have to
worry about peeing myself because I
didn't need to feed myself because I am
the direct beneficiary of generations of
white privilege now telling the story of
white privilege is important because
very often people say oh we want more
companies like yours we want more rcos
we want more black owned businesses
female-led triple bottom line ban the
box green manufacturing companies right
but the question we have to ask was
where's the wealth where's the money
where is the capital in our communities
to build type of business
that we want and in telling a story of
the white side of my family I named a
dozen ways where blacks were excluded
from the economy whereas the white side
of my family was able to gain access and
traction and build wealth primarily
because racism and capitalism are best
homies but but what that means is that
when we ask ourselves you know why are
our communities broke like we're not
just broke because we're broke or broke
for a reason
historical context really does matter
but our history tells another story as
well there's this incredible book called
collective courage which is the story of
how thousands of African Americans have
been able to build businesses and
schools hospitals farming cooperatives
banks financial institutions entire
communities and sovereign economies
without a lot of capital and they did it
by working together and leveraging their
community assets and trusting each other
and putting solidarity first not just
profits by any means necessary and they
didn't have to wait around for
celebrities and athletes to bring their
money back to the head however if you
are a celebrity an athlete and you're
listening to this please feel free to
bring your money but they did it through
cooperative economics because they knew
that capitalism was never going to
finance black liberation so there's so
many great examples in this book and I
suggest that everybody just read it
because it answers the question I asked
earlier which is where we're gonna get
the wealth to build the types of
businesses that we want and the answer
is gonna have to be cooperative
economics there's a lot of different
versions of co-operativism what I'm
talking about today is worker ownership
so you may not have heard of worker
ownership yet but it's been an
incredible tool for black economic
liberation for a century and it's also
working all over the world right now you
may have heard of black Wall Street or
maybe the zapatistas but I'll give you
an example that's a little bit closer to
home right now today in South Bronx is
the country's largest worker owned
company it's called cooperative homecare
associates and it was founded by black
and Latina home care workers who are now
able to pay themselves
living wages they have full-time hours
they have benefits in the pension
through their membership as a unit of
SEIU and these women owners now receive
a dividend back on their ownership every
year that the company has been
profitable which has been most years so
they're able to really enjoy the fruits
of their labor because they fired the
boss they don't have any big investors
they don't have fat cat CEOs or absentee
owners taking the profit out of the
company they each pay in about a
thousand dollars over time in order to
gain ownership and now they own their
job now there's hundreds of more
examples of companies like this
springing up all across the country and
I'm so inspired by by what they're doing
because it really represents an
alternative to the type of economy we
have now which explodes all of us it
also represents an alternative to
waiting around for big investors to
bring chain stores or big box stores to
our communities cuz honestly those types
of developments they steal resources
from our communities they put our
mom-and-pop shops out of just out of
business they make our entrepreneurs and
to wage workers and they take money out
of our pocket and send it to their
shareholders so so inspired by all of
these stories of resistance and
resilience that I got together with a
few people here in Los Angeles and we've
created Lucy Lucy stands for the Los
Angeles Union cooperative initiative and
our objective is to create more worker
owned businesses here in Los Angeles so
far in the last year we've created two
Pacific Electric an electrical company
and Vermont gage carwash which is right
here in south-central some of you guys
might be familiar with it this longtime
car wash is now owned and operated by
it's 20 workers all of whom are union
members ago
so you might be wondering why the focus
on union worker ownership but there's a
lot of good reasons why the labor
movement is a natural ally to the worker
ownership movement in order to build
these companies that we want in our
community we're going to need a few
things we're gonna need money we're
gonna need people and we're gonna need
training unions have all of those things
America's working classes and paying
union dues for decades and with our
unions have been building dignified
decent and democratic workplaces for us
however Union jobs are on the steep
decline and as time for us to start
calling on our unions to really bring
all of their financial and political
capital to bear in the creation of new
Union were living wage jobs in our
communities also Union halls are full of
union members who understand the
importance of solidarity and the power
of collective action these are the types
of folks that want more union businesses
to exist so let's build them with them
learning from our union is learning from
our past learning from our peers are all
going to be very very important to our
success which is why I'd like to leave
you with one last example and a vision
for the future and that vision is
Mondragon Spain Mondragon Spain is a
community built entirely around worker
cooperatives there's 260 Plus businesses
here manufacturing everything from
bicycles to washing machines to
transformers and this group of
businesses now employs 80,000 people and
earns 1 and 12 billion year on revenue
every year and all the companies there
are owned by the people that work in
them they've also built universities and
hospitals and financial institutions I
mean imagine if we could build something
like this in South Central the late
mayor of Jackson had a similar idea he
wanted to turn his entire city into a
Mondragon like cooperative economy
calling his ambitious plan Jackson
rising and when I look at Ron design I
see really what working-class people can
do for ourselves when we work together
and make decisions for so
and each other and our communities and
what's really incredible about Mondragon
is that why we are dreaming about them
they are dreaming about us this
community in Spain has decided to launch
an international initiative to create
more communities like it all over the
world by linking up with unions by
supporting organizations like Lucy and
by educating folks about the worker
ownership model now here's what you can
do to be a part of it if you are a union
member go to your union meetings and
make sure that your union has a worker
ownership initiative and become a part
of it if you're an entrepreneur if you
have a small business or you're
interested in starting one then link up
with Lucy or another organization like
us to help you get started on the
co-operative model if you're a
politician or you work for one or you
just like talking to them please get the
city state federal and County
legislation passed that we need in order
to fund and support worker owned
businesses and for everybody else learn
about our history learn about our models
and seek us out so that you can support
us you can buy some less invest in us
lend to us and join us because it's
really going to take all of us in order
to build the more just and sustainable
and resilient economy that we want for
ourselves and our children and with that
I would like to leave you with a quote
from Arundhati Roy and she writes our
strategies should not be only to
confront the Empire but to lay siege to
it to deprive it of oxygen to mock it to
shame it with our art our literature our
music our brilliance our joy our sheer
relentlessness and our ability to tell
our own stories not the stories that
were being brainwashed to believe the
corporate revolution will collapse if we
refuse to buy what they're selling their
ideas their version of history their
Wars
their weapons their sense of
inevitability because no this
they'd be few and we be many they need
us more than we need them another world
is not only possible
she's on her way and on a quiet day I
can hear her breathing thank you